yeah he's the first fool to start saying
[__] on stage what's up fo podcast
what's up everybody Felipe spsa here and
Rodrigo Torres over there wearing his
big old sweatshirt and I'm wearing my
big
old um purple sweater with my lavaa
shirt that somebody gave me at the show
and I still don't know what lavata is
the only lavata I know it's a laata
market it's probably their softball team
or baseball team where you pick up the
fontas and bottom the roach eggs there
this full I'm just kidding man all the
way from Mexico there's a lot of Latino
comedian there super a which is not a
Latino um Supermarket but it is a lot of
Latino shop there huh yeah they
specialize in Latino foods but it wasn't
always like that huh no I think they
went with the times they went with the
times they adapted all because um along
the the what nio park there's a
Walgreens now but um I would say 20
years ago that was Pioneer Market back
in the day back in the days Pioneer
Market was connected to a Pioneer
Chicken but the Pioneer Chicken and the
Pioneer Market had nothing to do with
each other Pioneer Market was a market
they had in Echo Park before they had
any other markets and Pioneer Market
changed with the times CU they will s um
Carnitas oh back then yeah man that was
a spot that was a spot
pul everything and then um when that
market would clo shut down a taco truck
open the side and saw all the same stuff
they had inside the market capitalize on
that [__] yeah and also there was a
Johnson and Johnson's bro what do you
mean Johnson and Johnson's they to be a
market no my my Johnson Market oh okay I
was like damn and where was that at that
was in on boo Heights I went there at a
f on a field trip when I was in
kindergarten they were letting us know
that this is where where we're all going
to work one day damn and um I remember
um career day they gave me cookies there
man and and as soon as they gave me the
cookies I want to I want to work here
there were bomb or what there were like
little tiny little cookies you know
enough to get you hooked hell yeah bro
there were little cookies with a little
tiny dots a little sprinkles sprinkles
man different colors like a rainbow I'm
trying to picture that right now yeah
you know that the kcha they have like a
regular cookie but you know the little
sprinkles sugar yeah little dots the
color dots red yellow little red but it
a little cookie like a little and they
gave me like four of them in a little
bag they were still
warm a man it hook you up with a little
glass of milk no milk
I drink a lot of milk in um Elementary
School man I [__] myself a lot
guzzling and that's why I don't drink
milk today man so about anything but
milk almond milk almond milk what's up
man I heard your aunt got deported bro I
heard that she was trying to come back
with like five a truckload of pataas
full of of untaxed cigarettes bro that
would be a that would be a good day but
there should there is a couple ants out
there that need to be deported but no
nobody got deported everybody's over
there were afraid of ice huh knock on
your door just run just run man A lot of
people are worried man Even though
people are
worried even if they're legal it's like
but what are they worried about though
cuz I think if you really have they
don't bash it bro well that's what I'm
saying like you only have to worry about
stuff if you've really been doing
criminal activities and stuff and then
you know trying to hide from them I
don't know what are they going to waste
because it cost money to arrest and
Deport people right man high priority
first they did a mass deportation during
the Bill Clinton era man I remember they
they got a bunch of salvadorians a bunch
of
Nikos Mexican fools that had um that had
committed crimes here in G right and
gang ties with a green card it was a
federal federal thing and they deported
all those Foods man nobody protested for
those fols you know Latinos don't
protest for criminals dog I know man see
we know man we do our research yeah they
were they were um they were deporting
ms-13s 18 streets um a lot of king
cobras a lot of gangs from I would say
man a lot of Southern California gang
because I didn't hear about no Northern
gang being deported yeah big old
Enterprise play Boys Hey cuz remember
when that little kid got shot when that
drug deal gone bad over there in glasso
park behind Dodger Stadium when that
happened that's when Bill Clinton came
up with a three strikes rule right and
that that's when all that start stuff
started happening and everybody started
getting like raided and you know sent
back and whatnot I ended up playing
basketball one of the guys that was in
that car really there at um at glasso
Park [__] he yeah man I was one of the
guys oh [__] how'd you get out oh
technical difficulties damn I got a
cousin that's deported right now he's in
Tijuana I have a brother too bro yeah
he's in his 40s trying to come back yeah
he never got he never got legally done
or whatever he just had his like little
green card but he was a criminal fool so
what he do there you go uh all types of
[__] dude I don't know he was like all
jacked up on like tweak and bunch of
stuff so when you have a green card and
you're if you get arrested now just now
during the Trump Administration
and you're a resent alien like you have
a green card and you've been here since
you were five but now you commit a crime
just they um you have a DUI and you run
over another you you hit somebody with
your car but they didn't die is that
ground for deportation right there it is
but check it out Charlie Beck the um
chief of LAPD said that they're not
going to act as ice agents or federal
agents they're not going to deport them
so there's an issue right there Trump
saying federally that yeah you got to
get out of here cuz you did that but
locally these fols ain't going to do the
fed's job so now there's an issue you
know right for high priority yeah there
you go it's funny how um but that's like
a hit and run we're not going to enforce
we're not going to
enforce the federal law you know which
you know the Trump Administration said
but if we're going to allow marijuana
sales in our in our city and forget
about the what the DEA thinks about it
they want that tax forget about the CIA
because um it's funny how when you the
state people complaining why the
president did this the president that
it's the state you're in it's the way
the the your state is governed because
it's it's legal to have an abortion in
America you know Ro versus Wade they
made it IL legal now they now some
states don't hold that federal law like
Texas they don't want they don't want
people to get abortions the South a lot
of fights going on between federal law
and state law what they believe in huh
state rights and then like you know then
they go to their higher court and then
they has to get H by the Supreme Court
then they don't hear it then it stays
the same in that state then you crawl to
another state where it's legal and do
your abortion if you want you can't take
away Ro versus weight huh well they're
trying to like they've been trying since
I was a little
kid little bit chipping away a little
bit yeah well they yeah they have to
like you know legal ruins like is it
constitutional now I got now is this is
a is the Supreme Court going to hear it
but they're trying it's just interest
groups and lobbying you
know totally then you go that they say
that um I don't want my tax do going for
abortions really they should be going
for potholes I I don't want my money
going for Planned Parenthood should be
going for street lights and then but the
way they spin it was that is that I I've
been to Planned Parenthood usually when
you go to plann Parenthood all plans
failed already you had no plans should
call it unplanned Parenthood they should
call it unplanned Parenthood because
when you go there man it's like you have
no more
plan usually when a person goes to um
planed Parenthood it's because I I knew
a girl that worked she didn't work in
Planned Parenthood but she worked at a
place for Central of disease this so she
would hear stories like a a 15year old
girl being gang raped you know or being
being gang banged by a bunch of high
school kids and she catches some like
diseases on her and nobody else helping
her so she will go there for help I
don't know she worked there but she
would give her like condoms they would
give her a drug test you know check her
her her give her medicine for her
disease condition and then if she was
pregnant then they would send her to
plan Parenthood that's the last you but
um I'm just thinking um without Planned
Parenthood without these people helping
you who the [__] is going to help you
man well that's when the government
steps in and helps you with programs
like planed Parenthood but and then
there's funding and that helps out
people as the last resort dude it's
there for some reason right need
help who going to get to that who going
to get to that all those things that you
can't afford if you don't have resources
pre natal care the planet and also when
you go to plan Parenthood it's like they
help you go other places like just say
you're a young mother and you know that
a father going to be there know then you
got to go to Wick they sign you up for
Wick women in chlas no that's women in
care right what it stand for women
infants and children women's infants and
children that's another program but they
also when you go to plan parent you go
through the it's like on that book on
what to do What to Expect When You're
Expecting they help you out through the
N9 months like you go in there they set
you up with a doctor that's going to
give the birth set you up with a
hospital pretty much um they help you
along the way through your pregnancy if
cuz it's not just abortion cuz if you're
going to have the baby they're going to
help you all too oh yeah and not they're
going to shut the do down no get out of
here pregnant chick all we do is
abortion here [__] yeah well that's the
thing everybody it don't work that way D
cuz um they help you out they help you
out dude a funny story that I did a show
one time Bakersfield and one of the
comedians had sex with somebody and when
they looked up in a parking lot there
were having mistak inside the the the
Planned Parenthood parking lot parot in
the little shopping center win in Rome
yeah so what else do they do Lisa they
do breast exam breast exams gam
preventative medicine also any type of
women function like AED you know
migraine you
murderer
this
least I only went there for women's
services like psme you know they do that
for you and um birth control oh yeah
it's funny man like if to but you know
what man it's just that whoever has the
money controls the media like if you and
I had like a million dollars to spare
you know we could um we could pretty
much bash any comedian any any movie
story we can have
we got pay somebody to write a nice
article and put it out there and put it
out there like the other article that
800,000 illegals voted for Hillary and
that's why she won the popular vote yeah
that's what what's his name is getting
all crazy cuz you were saying that um
we're talking about it when we were over
there in Atlanta that homeboy was uh all
mad and he wants that checked out right
but it's the only reason he wants it
checked out in my opinion was because he
saying to try to sway the popular vote
that he wanted it's like come on dog but
it's like are illegal people really
going to vote they're not not going to
count hey let me tell it's hard
basically for an illegal person to get a
driver license you think after he gets a
driver license illegally he's going to
make incriminate himself and walk into a
[__] a a voting a voting boo I'll
paranoid and [__] oh yeah that's what
I'm with [__] federal agents there
watching him hell no he's going to be
try to be under the radar you know I
think Donald Trump must have been
watching the history The Gangs of New
York before he started after the
election bro and started watching
another
recop Irish people man if you guys want
to watch the way the world is changing
right now the way Trump thinks and the
way the things are happening go watch
Gangs of New York what's the the main
actor name uh Daniel de Lewis and listen
to everything that Daniel de Lewis says
about Irish people and then close your
eyes and pretend that Daniel de Lewis is
not saying those things about Irish
people but just say he's saying it about
Mexicans and saying about Muslims
because everything that Daniel L was
saying about Irish people is what
they're saying about Mexicans and
illegal immigrants now it's all that
nativism dude it was [__] sad man at
least man these Irish people were coming
into the country in boats and they were
throwing rocks at them bro you [__]
Irish NWS yeah or and go they were
saying these [__] Irish they do the
jobs that black people would do for $10
and they're do it for six taking our
jobs they're taking our jobs and um but
godamn bro like that ain't [__] dude the
way like he was we like ji Lewis he's a
nativist which pretty much is a
nationalist right he's for he's part he
could trace his blood to to the original
13 colonies but fool this guy hates
Irish people like hates them bro but he
hasn't working for him no but he's going
with the times you know he's going with
the times but there's a part in the
movie where the the you know the the the
waves you know the the times are
changing for for Daniel Day Lewis in the
movie because shitload of Irish people
are coming in there's a sad thing right
here man Irish family comes in and um so
they give his wife and son a piece of
bread and a soup and right away the guy
goes vote for tenan oh yeah so that's
he's buying a vote and at the same time
he's sending her husband they're sending
his husband to go fight in a civil war
man imagine you just got to this country
and all of a sudden they give you a gun
and in sad these irish guys are going in
the boat they're getting on a boat while
while while C Cask is full of dead
people are coming in and they're talking
with their Irish asking or redheaded F
going where we're going we're going to a
place called Tennessee I've never heard
of it yeah D inant americ dude yeah man
so man life was [__] up for immigrants
back then yeah but he also Al got to
think all those Irish people are coming
from a potato famine so they don't have
[__] F they're eating air dog so you
know what I mean that little bread and
water means a lot dog so and then you
got all those people hating on you
throwing rocks at your ass so the same
thing that Daniel De le is saying about
Irish people they're saying about
immigrants now like they say like um
these Muslims come in you know and they
don't um they go with Shah Law whatever
yeah yeah and um they don't want to be
Americans fundamentalist and this is
what Dani de LS was saying about the
Irish the Irish Pig
they show allegiance to the pope before
they show allegiance to America because
they're Catholic bro well when JFK was
running for president they were talking
the same [__] too it's crazy man yeah it
doesn't stop fool you know but American
but as far as um showing allegiance to
America no one no nationality shows
allegiance to America the way Mexican
Americans do because we still byy
American man you look at our our parking
lots it's all chevret it's all dodg it's
all Fords you know we wear night
oh yeah we want to be Americans just
give a little chance well dude um we buy
we every movie we would if you ask any
like Mexican American in a country what
movie you want to go see that new movie
coming out with [__] all the Marvel
Superheroes or that new movie that's
coming out with Andy Garcia and um er J
almost almost about the the [__]
walkouts I'm have to go see X-Men dog I
[__] watch that other movie on
Netflix yeah and you can tell when like
Mexican Americans become cops that's why
they're so good at their job and they
become like a hardcore like
anti-immigrant anti- cholo dude because
they want to prove themselves dog so so
um that that the guy from T Hall tell T
Hall tells um what's the name
ardio you know we're going to get these
vs together right and um then he goes um
but um I'll do it but we got to you got
to also um support uh one of my one of
my Irish guy's going to run for office
he go that fool looks at he goes yeah
man when the queen has a
dick cuz he had the muscle he straight
up say are you [__] kidding oh never
he said never like what do that mean are
you [__] stupid that means [__]
never oh yeah dude but
so all all they could just squeeze all
was um letting a guy run for Sheriff and
he became the first Irish Sheriff but
then they went to his house and killed
that mother [__] nobody say [__] right
and at that time that's when a lot of
Irish people were becoming going in the
police force but what you're talking
about with the whole generational shift
it goes from when Leonardo Deca was a
little kid to a full-blown adult dog so
a lot of [__] changed so D Lewis did not
want to work with the Irish right he
didn't care about them like he didn't
care about their votes he didn't care
about nothing but that guy from tmy Hall
did so that's when he stepped in and
said well man it's time to take out
Daniel de Lewis he's not going with
changing with the times he's too old his
way of thinking is done but this guy was
seeing numbers bro oh [__] that's all it
is is numbers numbers man go go now dog
he said you're over there throwing rocks
at them and hurting them I'm giving him
soup he goes what I know what you're
doing man you think you're just buying
votes so then when he killed that Irish
guy he go you know what this is right
here the minority vote yeah but it can
also shift dude and be the majority do
cuz that would rather have a a Black
Fool working side byy with him than an
Irish fool well they hated him so bad in
that sense dude that native is since
just hat it huh oh yeah dog so that
those those were white people going at
it dog man when you tell you man when
when there's no black people and Latino
people and Muslim people to [__] with
why people know how to improvise well
divide and conquer dude the grand old
rule they go you know what that man yeah
he might be Irish but he's a Catholic
bro yeah fool that means a lot dog there
you go it's Jewish bro There You Go fool
but a lot of fools were coming in back
then bro not just Irish people Africans
too Italians Italians bro they were the
next people to get this on yeah and you
go with the ships in American uh
immigration it goes like they block out
the ones that are like Eastern European
is less it's like you know more like
towards you know England and all that
stuff crazy bro so you're 2% Jewish huh
1% 1% yeah the good percentage it's red
all right people this February this
February getting back to business this
February I'm going to be on the on the
festival laugh tour with Mike eps more
Bruce Bruce Rick Smiley Ricky Smiley
Tony Rock and many many more February
will be in Orlando Cincinnati Raley
North Carolina and Dallas Texas also Al
all these
shows Rodrigo T we Hank will be tagging
along as a road manager and yeah man
commandant so you could say hi to him
backstage also how they going to get
there this Friday you know how they get
there bro H this Friday upcoming shows
February 3rd I'll be in Orlando Florida
Saturday February 4th Cincinnati Ohio
I'll be a guest on the Mike EP show also
man this in Orlando our senior OHA will
be there so woo woo woo Let's Get Busy
February 14 Chicago one night only with
Mike EPS Bruce Bruce and Tony Rock next
week February 10 Raleigh North Carolina
February 16th through the 19th Pleasant
in California with to te these tickets
are going fast people so hurry up
February 23rd to the 26 San Antonio
Texas at The Improv River Center also
check out filipes world.com tour for all
the info everybody thank you very much
for leaving comments on Twitter
Instagram but more importantly iTunes we
were number 139 [__] yeah all right
shout outs to these heads here here
shout out to everyone who reviewed us on
iTunes Danny starwind and Don V Perez
and a big happy birthday shout out to
Emilio G who's been listening and
supporting since the beginning happy
birthday and go follow emoor g69 on
Instagram fool I was watching that show
Rose
battle what way that show that show was
all right it sucks man be like that
opinion that the best thing I ever seen
of that is they had Cory hul judge I
don't like that first of all
it's different from first of all people
if you're going to watch this show think
it's going to be a street roast battle
when two people are bagging each other
it's nothing like that it's a rose
battle like a rose battle like the one
you watching comedy central where the
all the jokes are written and blah blah
blah blah so they had these two Mexican
comedians right one of half Irish and
one of half Mexican and the other one
was all Mexican and they introduced them
with Mexican music Mariachis a pinata
and then they introduced the other guy
with a pinata and mariachi music and
Mexican music and then the host did aot
bunch of jokes about Mexicans Home Depot
the wall this and that then Jeffrey Ross
did more jokes about Mexicans and I'm
thinking to myself man let me tell you
right now man if I was on that show if I
was the guest I would have said
something like I would have said
something like well first of all that
guy he's one of those whitewash Mexicans
you know but that's nothing that's
nothing to do with that you know he
opened up with I didn't really speak
Spanish
instead of saying um instead of saying
something like what the [__] Central is
this roast you guys roasting Mexicans or
what the [__] you know because they
don't introduce any white comedian with
a bunch of um class members coming in
you know or a bunch of Republicans
coming introduce the white guys or a
bunch of African guys running around
naked you know when to introduce a black
guy coming in you know what I mean oh
yeah and first of all when you're and
then whenever there's a a a roast at The
Comedy Store between a Mexican guy and a
white guy the white guy right away goes
to the to get racial like build a farm
build a wall or go pick fruits cuz let
me tell you in a real real rose battle
in a real real rose battle a white guy
will never have a chance because first
of all as soon as he gets racist he's G
to get punched in the face I'm serious
The Punch Battle any anybody who roastes
me anybody in the streets roastes me and
then goes racial I'm going to beat the
[__] out of him because you're being
racist now you know what I mean because
I had a rose battle with my friend
Ronald Paige coko a black guy uhuh we
[__] bagged on each other's mom for
two hours not one time not one time that
I think about in my head saying anything
about black people or they run so fast
or calling him the nword stereotypes
yeah and he never not one time called me
a wet back during the road roast or did
he call me a fruit picker during the
roast he just made man he made fun of my
mom hard your man you [__] mom with
[__] 10 kids which is you know what I
mean so that's my view on the rose
battle man and first of all man how how
is um Jeffrey Rock was on the rose
General after GRE Jadoo died yeah
there's there's only one you were just a
rose Sergeant liutenant yeah man like
take your stripes so I don't know man
that's my thing about it man I I didn't
like that the way those those two
Mexican comedian who were introduced
with Mexican music because man when I
first started doing standup comedy
that's how they introduce me like no
matter what show I was on I was always
like the you got ready for some Spanish
flavor some [__] whenever I did a black
show I did a black show the black
comedian would always say you got ready
to spice things
up oh I did a white a show with I'm the
only comedian with a when a white
comedian is a host all right man we're
going to bring some Latin flavor to this
show with Filipe Esparza and then
they'll bring out they'll play a song
called so that I was always introduced
like that bring you up to always always
was introduced like that every let in
comedian you know so when I saw it on
the on the that comedy rol I said wow
man that's the way they think of us
still yeah history repeats itself that's
the way they really think about us bro
with marashi music and not not all
Mexican music don't like music oh yeah
but I think going well that's not that's
for the ratings that's why I I know but
but everybody in audience is laughing
bro it's [__] laughing and then and
then I know I know those two people that
were on the show didn't expect that but
but you know what man hey man that's the
way that's the way com Central thinks
about you bro they think about when they
think about Mexican comedians all they
think about patas even when you're half
cuz I know by a fact if that was our
magic girl on that show they would have
done done that oh yeah CU they never
done that that they would have never
done that you know maybe if if gabri GL
was on the show probably they would have
done that you know that's why I would
never do no roast you know they invite
me to do a roast I wouldn't do the roast
because that's going to open up a bunch
of Home Depot jokes they could get away
with you know what I mean oh yeah well
that's what they're doing I'm going to
make their job easier for them cuz I'm
pretty sure don't nobody got together
and wrote anything cuz they just said oh
Mexican guys [__] throw in pinatas oh
yeah but
for a real roast battle be two
[__] just chilling right there
going at it bagging on each other no
notes no nothing dog let's see what you
can do oh no I got to get prepared I got
to get prepared and then um first and
then another thing it's like when you're
doing a battle it's like this the
funniest meme I ever saw it was like
this they show this white guy in his
computer and then he was going to press
the N an NW and on the bottom it said
when a white guy losing a a political
battle on Facebook this is the letter he
this the first word he PR up and the end
so that was my view man you saw it bro
what do you think I I've never seen I've
seen it one two times at The Comedy
Store and I thought it was kind of lame
the way they set it up George Lopez was
going after um you say he was roasting
um that old comic no it was a Perez
George Perez against Erol sko but he
said some racist [__] I just walked out
I was like dude yeah he said um you
fruit picker some [__] like that see R
first of all I don't know who earol sko
is but I know George Perez George Perez
is a known Thug back in the days and in
a real rose bottle I don't think earol
SK would have called him a fruit picker
because [__] he knows that [__]
George Perez is a beast I don't you you
know what I mean yeah was it just trying
to be funny with that racist [__]
it's like um if you're GNA show the same
respect to Al magika as a Mexican
American I think everybody should show
the same respect to everybody well
that's everybody don't just look at him
well I can't do that around here yeah
well they if you don't got a name you
don't you don't show them respect it's
like when we go we want to go do that
radio station the guy the first question
they ask us any radio station now about
the wall about the wall like can we move
on I guess we can L how about Builder
first oh yeah it's it's already there
right what the [__] killing me dude yeah
we'll say call
[Laughter]
now but like what's up fool
yeah like Cory hul said they all
suck what's up fool
what's up fool yeah who's this this is
Andrew man Andrew what's up Andrew from
where uh I'm living in Long Beach man
but I'm originally from
Bakersfield B so what up how's
everything man man shit's shit's going
good how you guys doing we're over here
man chilling listening to you dog how
long you been listening to the
podcast [__] man since I heard you on uh
Church what's happening now probably the
first time man oh you're old school
listener huh hell yeah dude I I already
forgot what I said on the church what
happening the which which time like the
first one you did the first one yeah I
think so just some great stories man
[__] I'm always thinking about man
because I I didn't know how podcast work
you know so I'm always think about did I
incriminate myself with a violent crime
on any podcast statute of limitations
only out on that [__] snitching on
yourself yo
what snitching on yourself hey oh snitch
myself
yeah so what's up man are you afraid are
you afraid they going to deport your
wife or your
friends nah man I'm I mean I was born in
California so no but I'm worried for
everybody else this [__] it's a [__]
show right now yo it's crazy man hell
yeah all this Mass he already got like
46 Federal lawsuits against him you seen
that [__] yeah man that's a lot of
lawsuits yeah that F's been sued a grip
of times dude I didn't know you could
sue a presidential this presidency oh
yeah I think they lawsuits against all
those fools those are lawsuit against
aordable K too right fromex trying to
knock it
down yeah so what's up man yo can I be
real for a second yeah got about 10
minutes I got I got about 10 minutes
through that cristella special before I
cut that [__] off
bro it was too low classic for you huh a
lot of pampering huh yo this shit's bro
all right all right what was corny about
it dog her tennis shoes I don't know one
of the tags was literally like oh what
did I drop the truth like get the [__]
out of here you're dropping the truth
dog hey y'all didn't I had to come hey
that reminds me of um the old comics and
those are the
women right how fat was she that's
that's funny man did what did I drop on
you guys the true
she's new reality bro you're brutal bro
you're brutal
bro yeah cuz if a comic would say that
go oh dude he's just hating and [__]
it's like yeah man I can't comment no
more on people's comedy so I don't I
don't even watch it I still oh no I'm
sure yeah no I I understand but there's
some stuff out there like there's some
let me tell you man Mex um Netflix is
putting a lot of whack Mexican comedians
bro I saw two of them the other
day it's like they're just giving
specials man and one was one was
Bolivian whoa and hey don't don't say
[Music]
nothing that's
crazy this how many y man did you did
you give that
special what's that how many y man did
you give that special I give it a no man
o I gave it a negative3
y you know it's funny you say that [__]
to three yeah man because the guy that
says yeah man when he say yeah man he's
really hating yeah that's where it all
came from i' I've figured that out at
this
point like yeah man keep
talking 17,000 on the scratcher yeah man
well thanks for calling bro and thank
you for uh reviewing the the the the
special but not so
special thank you for H blunt honest man
much for the podcast you guys are
amazing hell yeah keep shining hell yeah
oh 100 keep shining I will bro I'm
shining right now what happened D best
special I saw it I it's a fat ass ball
before it wases up really hell yeah he
let to smoke out in the audience my
first special oh and that's his first
comedy special yeah oh hell yeah I
respect that man he's I thought that had
four specials well no I know he did the
marijuana Logs with Arch Barker back in
the day we're talking 2000 2001 2002
there was another guy that used to work
with him that was really funny there
three of them Kenny Kam something like
that Kevin K yeah there's three of it's
that dude Arch Barker and him well the
other guy he's hilarious bro
Kevin Andy Kam or something they had
that poster at the at the Andy [__] I
don't know he was I saw him open up for
a show with gabri glaas and he went up
on stage with a his cell phone he like
one of those 90s cell phones those big
ass like a 20 minute B out it man oh
really hell yeah
but uh those fools always kept it real
they've been podcasting for days do you
did the Doug movies back in the day over
there at uh the comedy club in Austin
what's the name had a funny joke what's
the other guy name with the long hair
Barker arge Barker yeah man he had a
funny joke about how you know how the
hacking comedians they do the joke about
hey man next time the plane crashes put
me make how come you don't make the
whole whole plane out of the black box
if that's going to survive and and then
and then he was thinking about how when
when when um in Star Wars when they were
shooting at the at that at when they
were being in that trash compactor and
they were shooting the the [__] snake
that was inside the water and it was
ricochetting all over the trash
compactor but the trash compactor wasn't
broken hey guys why not build the whole
[__] death out of the trash
compactor Ricochet in those punch lines
Tony Cami oh okay yeah Tony camon Tony
Camin camine come bro what are we
thinking bro well just you know I'm
making everybody Italian
today anyway that guy is hilarious very
underrated if you want to talk about
underrated comedians hell yeah dude
what's up
fool what's happening bro what's up doc
what's up Mr 213 how are you who is this
this is uh martinz Randle from salake
City remember that came to the show
what's up PO that's what I was gonna
tell you guys dude I was waiting you
guys to have a calling show because I
would telling I recently I had some
family like yeah we watched that new SP
on Netflix like oh yeah man he came he
came in my birthday yeah I got to hang
out with him and it was real cool he his
buddy they let me come in they let me
smoke with and right when I
was Liar
Liar oh there a f that came you a green
room yeah I F with the glasses and
everything he had those tiny blunts yeah
he had the um he was had the but
remember you said that one guy that was
working with you had a trump sticker and
you're what a disgrace yeah that's this
fo yeah yeah he went to a green room
yeah he said he he can't wait to see Joe
Diaz yeah man yeah dude was funny
because uh I was like yeah you came into
the green room and you saw me his were
wide open like uh the show's over Dude
show's over bro what are you doing I'm
just kind of sitting there like uh hey
man it's all
nervous so what's up what happened F any
of your family get deported or what they
were asking me you really met him I'm
like yeah I really met
him he don't e
meat you don't eat
meat I know don't eat meat though
believe it dog he the bread called B
bimbo give it up for the summary dog so
any what's the hysteria going like over
there in Utah fool anybody getting
deported or what just really really cold
real cold weather you know it's been
snowing real hard lately um damn has
been uh but the Air's bad you know Air's
we're waiting for some for some rain to
clear each other this air up but it's
it's been pretty good you know what I
mean not too not too
shabby hell yeah so what's up fool man
not much F I was listening to some of
your guys' older [__] today because um
you know obviously you guys don't you
can only you can only wait for a week
for so long you know what I mean and uh
I was listening to your first and I I
don't know what it is about that story
man or just entirely just I think I just
keep cracking up more just because
because you don't remember much of the
night I don't even know if you remember
much of your first podcast but you're
telling the story about how you were
[__] up and you were trying to kill
some Pisa and I don't know why do I just
like you gotta listen to this [__]
podcast man I'm like going around going
crazy telling everyone you gota listen
to this [__]
podcast oh you're talking
about you're talking about when I took
Juan Garcia in the car and then we were
chasing the other
car no no the one where you had some
crazy Pisa and you guys were all getting
and you you tried to take the TV Court
you're like I'm G kill this
fool oh yeah that that was in um man I
forgot about thato I forgot everything I
did that night that was in um you were
with those two shs and yeah that was
Central
Shino yeah
branish I was listening to that I was
like d man he speak better than I do all
these bgh that how Central bro that guy
ended up going to prison bro for trying
to kill another guy that was at that
party yeah that see that but that's how
great that story is you know there's an
ending yeah man that girl in jail that
guy's in jail I trying to charge $100 to
hang out bro I know you saying you're
like you he's like hey man that guy TR
charges taking us here and there I just
couldn't start laughing up the phone
part took that fool's phone and you're
all like he kept calling and calling
you're he ain't going to call me no more
dog
[__] you don't give a [__] boom you
left your [__] phone at the producers
oh oh [__] it I don't even know why we
took that guy's phone now yeah what
because he he uh you thought he St his
dude I just recently listen to this one
that's why I know so much about it
because you you thought you took your
phone you thought you took your phone
and you let at the
producers that's right so you were
[__] you were like this fo kept
calling you and calling you you're at
the casino you said they were saying and
that you were [__] Le and you're like
this boy ain't gonna call me no more and
you [__] smashed it against the
wall I did wow dude the funniest part of
that story is when Richard Chang
recreates a thing when you're pulling
out the cord from the TV and just
walking around breathing I'm going to
kill this fol
dog you just get riled up dog I'm glad
nobody agre
be like
that the dude who played cha yeah Daman
Chapa man that [__] is I'm just bar
toward that one but you guys you know
it's I don't know why listening to the
other ones it's just like I don't know
it's like I feel like yesterday you know
I'm always like when I I feel like you
guys are talking about yesterday or
something it's [__] crazy they don't
feel old or
older Yeah man so anybody listening God
you should definitely start releasing
some of the older ones if you feel like
you're not getting enough doing one F
good Public Service Announcement thank
you
bro and listen to the Yad podcast cuz
that's also a great one too and I'm
still waiting for new
inch it's coming
bro it's in the oven right now it's
cooking I kind of want to put you on the
spot you need to get on that one for
that the new what the new inada oh she
said
podcast you guys need a new one dog it's
like November think November 23rd since
you guys had one but who's counting this
Bo is that would be nice CU my sister
was saying hey if you talk to them let
know you didn't lie that I was like yeah
let him know but yeah we got a new one
coming bro we lot stuff that
happened I figured you guys don't have
time because you guys must be killing it
we stopped doing it we didn't stop doing
it because we got busy during the
holidays then a a rabbit slippers was
sick for about two weeks and then um
Isaac left then he came back
well I I wanted to tell you you need to
make a sticker or a shirt with slippers
on it dude and that says what's up
because I think slippers every time you
take your pictures on Instagram like man
his [__] rabbit's dope he to get a
really sick ass photo of
thatb Man slippers B Rodrigo the other
day because she wouldn't he wouldn't pet
her I pet her I stopped petting her then
she' like bit me on the thigh oh fool
yesterday we had slippers outside right
chilling and the squirrel came right man
you you should have seen that rabbit man
she just ran inside the house and got
under the table and then R and then um
my son went outside to look at that
squirrel and that squirrel was waving
her tail like yeah [__] what's up
what's up what's up I never seen a
[__] squirrel do that bro she was
waving the tail like something little
communication thing going on there dude
they want to be buddies that are letting
her know what's up little gangster ass
squirrel down I forget you guys are in
California it must be sunny days every
day not last week bro it was raining for
it ran for two week straight bro they
say it's coming too again this week yeah
we uh we beat the drought yeah for now
yeah I was going to say you guys you
guys needed that you guys really needed
that water especially with all the
[__] up roads like for water
and [__] year sh yeah man what's up
fool thanks for calling bro all right
Martinez Rand yeah dog was nice talking
to Martinez Rand in the house with his
glasses no nice talking to you dog chill
out on the Red Bulls I want a shout
out you got a shout out Rand shout out
for bringing those skinny blunts oh
yeah like it's funny went now he showed
up to the green room and he opened up
his hand he rolled up those three blunts
like they were already
[Laughter]
there thanks bro let some Jas bro all
right bro get some [__] bedtime
stories for your ass [__] yo [__]
that
[__] don't forget the Tam yeah a lot of
these fools think because um J Diaz
talked to way he talks on on on the
podcast and he talks the way on stage
and the way you talk on on the mic here
and the way you talk on stage I'm pretty
sure most other the other podcast
listeners here on a comedy D re you know
whoever the way we talk they think that
they could talk to us like that in
public bro it's not the same do I don't
we don't do a a Walkin podcast [__]
walking like you can't walk up to J out
of knowwhere he don't know him go hey
[__] you'll scare him folk you'll
scare him bro he proba R you can't walk
up to him go what's up fool he might
punch you bro you don't know what what's
going on man he might be an enig I get
startled what man man a lot of rappers
coming out of Mexico bro they all sound
that like MC bro they're just jumping on
everything that's popular fool you know
they're trends that everybody wants to
bank on I like the rapper named ma bro
where's where's he from I don't know bro
he had a tattoo on his face he was a
real ganga damn m is from down over here
the mexo okay
M what's happening
fool what's up fool what's up fool where
you calling from you sound familiar like
a past
caller no man first time caller long
time listener oh thank you out here from
Irving Texas Irving Texas bro I know
where that is
Irving Texas Home was the original
Cowboy stadium Irving Irving Irving um
it's Irving it's um on King of the Hill
Arland
Arland sure there you live with the King
of the Hill
huh not Irving Texas in Dallas oh okay
next to Dallas right I'm coming to
Dallas
bro when for one night only with Mike
EPS oh [__] I'm to come and check you
out man every time you come I never get
a chance to come out and see
you but I'm going back to arlingon um
Texas in the
fall that's what's up that's what's up
what's up Rodrigo what's up playboy
what's up bro you sad are you sad they
deporting everybody or
what ah [__] [__] man you know
how it is they can't they can't keep us
down we still shining hell yeah dog I
think it's all [__]
fool what you guys
think safe bro yeah I don't know I just
think it's getting blown up by the media
dog honestly dude I think uh we're
living in a time bro where um this this
um what they call that this what when
they have this party yeah man we're
going to be we're going to be run by
fear bro this this is a time where where
a lot of news are going to come out just
to scare everybody man keep everybody on
check well remember after 911 everybody
was pro war dog remember let's go get it
I know man people forget like how many
how many like right after 911 how many F
how many Mexicans were against Muslims
bro oh yeah that's what I'm saying fool
everybody goes with the trends dude
everybody's trendy fool you got to spin
it right yeah hell yeah or you know like
they say the orang says is I remember
like when we had you remember we had
that um that Vietnamese food right here
Milana yeah and I was telling her
telling her that when all the Vietnamese
were coming to the neighborhood how
there was a li being sprad I getting new
cars oh yeah they probably got one
little shitty car and that was it no gas
no but they the government didn't give
no cars bro the church the church give
them cards there somebody
did yeah man what's up F how's
everything over there bro you waited for
the Super Bowl who you going
for ah [__] I really don't
care me neither bro I'm gonna be
watching
golf hey they they [__] with my UFC
now man now some of Fighters are getting
held up because of that uh
anti-immigration
[__] oh that's right a love UFC fighter
from another country they can't come
into the country especially Brazilian
Fighters UFC
Mexico [__] and the Mexican stars are on
the come up right now
man like which one bro Velasquez like
Rodriguez he's cold
man hell yeah I know bro I don't watch
too much UFC bro I've never watched the
only UFC match I ever watched was the
last McGregor and Nick Diaz one that was
it I don't know bro Chicago if I want to
if I want to wrestle with somebody bro
I'll do it in my
bedroom too close for comfort
r no no Jiu-Jitsu with with Joey huh man
Jo Jo Jiu-Jitsu once a month right give
it a couple kicks and then I go home bro
that's
it y'all catch him y'all catch him on
that uh on that eats episode where eats
the hot wings no I just seen a little uh
little quick little thing on Instagram
how many hot wings he
ate he ate them all he ate them all that
[__] was hilarious man I ate up the
storm I like hot wings bro but I'm not
too good about the Buffalo ones man I
like barbecue garlic I'm tell you one of
some of the best hot wings ever in my
life it was that the wild coyote dog yes
it was Lisa best hot wings hot water
coyotes what's that I thought you let
the wings over there okay nachos are
bomb too man the sometimes the wings are
long bro like they get the whole long
well they had the whole thing with the
nail and everything I didn't eat that
part Sweet Water T so what's up fool
what's your name again man ra how long
you been listening man since the
beginning yeah actually I think uh about
two years ago I bed all your episodes
caught up B and I I listen to the what's
up fool the uh yeah man and the Ed cro
thank you for listening bro hell yeah
dog [__] Raul thanks for listening
bro thank you for calling in bro yes yes
hell yeah Irving is always in our hearts
Irving
represent hell
yeah shout out to my to my boy uh Turtle
the truth out there he came out and saw
you guys when y'all came to the Addison
imp tur the truth was that that big ass
fool he kind of
tall no Turtle uh Carlos vkin all
right shout out to Carlos Turtle the
truth he's Emy with rabbit the
liar turtle turtle turtle the truth and
turtle of Jews that's what we call them
God damn this
one the three T's bro the truth can't
stop laughing do thanks for calling bro
all right Ro all right yall take it easy
peace right
man Turtle the
truth
hello what's up fool what's up fool
who's this this is Eric from silar Eric
for real oh what up fool how you living
dog happy New Year I'm good how about
you guys man right here bro surviving
bro living one day at a time one day at
a
time that's good man how you guys uh
have you guys seen that show yet the one
with the one on Netflix right was um
Rita Moreno Eric Griffin how is it
man what's that how's the show man I
think it's it's 280s for me it's not bad
but you know they they kind of do that
whole Hollywood uh Latino accent that
kind of kills it for me you know it's
like over done I mean it's the the the
story lines are pretty good but I don't
know it just seems like they never get
it right you know there's always
something what are you talking about
every time and every time like the
daughter has a boyfriend it's always a
white kid you know yeah so what can they
have another Hispanic kid you know I
don't know it's kind of weird are they
are they supposed to be Mexican Cuban
Salvadorian what are they well check
this they're Cuban but they live in Echo
Park wow yeah
they do a lot said in La they do a lot
of references to LA but it's uh you know
I don't think it's true to the to the to
the to the area you
know I know I I know because um if it
was if they were like Cubans in 1974 I
would have believed them you know
because there was a lot of Cubans in the
197 late 70s and in Echo Park but now
that but there's no there ain't that
many Cubans left but there's some
there's yeah small little and they um
they're always dropping portals like I
think the first episode she walks in
with big bags of portal and she's like
oh man first of my they're the producers
first of all man if you were Cuban in
those days in Echo Park you wouldn't go
to portal bro we making Cuban food in
your own house right no man you would
have been you would have been to um you
would have been to you would have went
to El coito right there on Sunset bro
was it around in the 70s but I don't I
don't know what year this show is based
on it's based now right yeah it's
present time man yeah so they would have
went toito right there bro with that
lady that give you a hug and give you
toast with butter
used to be real good would
caop that's they used to be a Cuban
owner right there and then if you want
to what's up fool no I was just gonna
ask you have you had a chance to see
that uh that skip that Melissa did with
aiz andari on SNL when they're in bed no
oh it's pretty good man I just thought I
just thought maybe you had seen it
because I remember I saw Melissa open up
for you at at Flappers a few years back
oh so M seor and aiz are on a sketch
together yeah well a hosted and she did
this [__] hilarious scene dude like
they're try to get freaky in bed and she
keeps on just [__] it up like she
just says things that are not you know
freaky I won't I won't tell you too much
but when you get a chance to check it
out it's a good scene it's with the
season Sor and theist ofor just look it
up on I mean on YouTube it's a good a
good kit man yeah dude I was at your
show at the the noo man you guys killed
it as always man you know good stuff man
thank you bro remember were you there at
the first show or the second show no I
made it to the second show man oh man
remember that couple that was that been
together 17 years oh yeah yeah you kep
kept on riding that yeah man they hit me
up on Facebook go you man you [__] it
up for me homie now I got to get married
so he's GNA ask her to get marry her and
they're going to get married on the 20th
anniversary of being to other boyfriend
and girlfriend finally finally
bro D he goes man you embarrassed bro
talk about no pressure ask her now there
is the for 20 years come on what
pressure tell you man that's good man
that's that's what you should do you
should girl that want you know guys to
pop the question should just hit you up
and be like hey I'm gon to be in the
front they'll tell you what they're
wearing then you could you know put the
guys on the
SPO all right guys I just wanted to
check in you know tell you guys you know
I'm still big fan so thanks for calling
bro you want to hear you want to go
watch a funny video Melissa seor did a
video she she was imitating a hacky
Mexican comedian and she called him she
called herself Caesar and she has a
mustache and she kind of look like
cheich and she does bit she does a
comedy bit in like an a Mexican cholo
voice oh this is Cesar right here um I'm
getting ready for my show man let check
in my checklist um jumping cables it's
hilarious all right I'll check it out
look I just it's on YouTube or what
YouTube yeah or yeah all right I'll
check it out man yeah check out the one
with the I'm sorry man because she
killed it on that one I know she hasn't
been getting too many scenes but like
this one she did really well we'll check
it out all right thanks man I'll see you
guys likewise be
fool hello what's up
fools what's up fools who's this this is
Jose from Norco how you guys doing man
good brother how you living all the way
from Norco bro next to the
prison yeah from the beautiful city of
San Jose man see you guys up here quite
a
bit we actually saw a girl get hit by a
car while we were waiting in line to see
you guys one night God damn was that the
last time I was there what's that b was
that the last time I was there last year
when that
happened uh not when you shot the
special but it might have been the time
before that yeah wow she got hit by a
car crossing the street well so so you
know how at The Improv there's those
troling tracks yeah and then there's
there's the uh what everybody waits in
line so I guess this girl decided to
cross the street to go Wai in line and
there was some guy in the car I guess
with his wife and his kids and uh they
were driving by they were looking at the
line and I guess they didn't see the
girl acrossing the street so when you
finally saw her she slowed down and mess
but just managed to just like knock her
on her butt and knock her over and the
whole like the entire crowd that was
there was just was like oh and uh so I
guess some people got pissed and was
trying to drag the dude out of the car
and dude panicked through it in reverse
hit like two other cars and just bounced
out of there before they dragged him out
that was that was some pretty crazy [__]
wow get a witness goddamn dog yeah it it
was pretty bad well I don't know what
happened after that but how you guys
doing man good man good thank you for
that little [__] synopsis dog that is
crazy
so what you guys what are you guys
talking about
today chilling dude [__] talking
about you know same same what happened
breaking news bro a prison in
Delaware has been taken over by the go
by the inmates bro they took they
knocked down all the guards just right
now dude Trump has to put on a Superman
suit and go save
them yeah well that happens doesn't
matter whose person that [__] always
happens doesn't it yeah is it this the
first time a a prison gets taken over it
always
happens yeah but like taking over taken
over that's a different thing you know
there's always revolts and [__] but yeah
man the research that wow and just start
shooting people until with bean bags
start start busting out those grenades
with
little it's crazy man so how how was it
when you were locked up
bro thank course that has not happened
I'm on the other side of the
law so you're an officer huh no no not
at all I I work at a law firm oh right
on dude what do you do all right man law
practice p p law oh [__] yeah dude what
Sun law patent law oh patent law oh man
patent trademarks copyright okay man you
into trademarks man I know a couple of
commedian
bro who are taking logos and making it
look chub being
fluffy you know my my you know Lisa she
used to work at a law firm for uh to
protect you know the little Twitter
bird the little logo the little logo
from
Twitter I know but I'm trying to get to
that a little Twitter
bird MH well it was a a person would
sawell that bird on a pants and called
it love
or what's it called
Live Free or Die why it doesn't matter
man so they were jacking it yeah they're
using the same L hey when you have a
when you have a patent on something most
of the most of the fight is is um trying
to get people to bring it down huh well
try to keep people from using your [__]
that's really what it is you know if
they're infringing on what you've made
then if they're doing it exactly the way
you do it then that's infringement but
let's say for example they take some
that's existing like RMC runmc is suing
somebody what's that rund DMC is suing
somebody right now for that logo that
somebody made for no somebody made for
them and someone else is using it now
which one the Walmart Walmart and Target
are selling rund DMC shirts without
giving nothing to runmc cuz that [__]
wasn't licensed it's licensed so
somebody's making money then yeah they
owe Millions bro without giving them
their cut yeah it it might be the label
the label they gave him permission damn
so I me and you know how that [__] Works
where you know once you once you you're
eager to sign that contract you know to
be on the label you don't really read
everything that's involved I mean you
almost you're shining your life away
pretty much anything that you create
becomes property of theirs if you're not
reading it correctly sounds like an MTV
contract well I wouldn't I wouldn't
know but yeah man that's cool dude I
love you guys do man heard every single
podcast you guys have ever done listen
to Rodrigo listen to enchilada casserole
too uh actually one of the funny things
is uh uh when enchilada uh enchilada
cerol first came out I think it was the
very first song that you guys used on
that podcast was uh an ed G was Spano
song yeah and it was a song that I
hadn't listened to probably about oh I
don't know 20 30 years and and uh that
kind of like started picking by my Pops
I had a call I haden't talked to him
like in forever but thank you for that
one man yeah we were able to squash some
[__] that we had talked about in a long
time and sparked by just that little
song yeah man my dad had Alzheimer's bro
but I think I heard everything's
forgotten No Looking
Back hey it was nice talking to you guys
I'm going to open this up for other
people because I'm sure everybody else
is trying to get in this but you guys
keep doing what you do man we appreciate
it and we'll see you next time you guys
are in town yeah thank you bro much love
F hell
yeah what's up
F what's up it's Victor from his monthly
chicken what's what's up Victor from
Eagle Rock Happy Birthday by the way
where's that [__] deing ass lady CET
the reaper I start going for a job I
don't know
for for [__] AT&T
dog guys how you good dude how do you
get through every [__] month dog he
went for AT&T bro yeah fo got a hot
phone I don't know dude I honestly don't
know I just realized like oh [__]
between 12:30 and 1 let me call right
now took like three tries so you live
over there by zanu chicken huh zanu
chicken no oh that's still Glendale my
bad yeah Eagle Rock I live in Eagle Ro
by organic oh yeah imag I went to
organic yesterday bro it had four
chicken taco vegan chicken tacos Taco
Tuesday H at least I had the jack fruit
Burrito Bomb I went there too then I
made a little left to uh Tommy
so Tommy is right there bro and right
next door there's a barber shop they
line you up bro yes the homie Greg and U
yeah what's the name of that barber shop
by the way Dynasty Cuts Dynasty Cuts bro
right next to Organics bro you want to
ever go on a Tuesday man go to Dynasty
Cuts right there on Colorado with Greg
and his brother right his brother I
think his brother-in-law brother-in-law
man those guys bro you could play you
could watch you could watch a football
game there wait for a haircut is that
right there where they uh wax your nose
hairs um I don't know I haven't been
there in a while
actually well bald you know for turn
yeah but they got everything they got
Taco bro across the street tommies and
that bakery bakery a Vietnamese and they
got a rib place next
door yeah I ain't down for no
ribs like that what up Victor talk to me
f talk to us bro has ice came to the
neighborhood how many people are scared
in Eagle Rock you get deported how many
Armenians are scared
bro uh nothing dude Rock pack as
always those are laying low like always
dog under the ring
yeah no it's uh everything's
normaly all that [__] happening you
know
um you can't really can't really be
surprised he said he what he's doing you
know I actually blame Obama for roasting
him on the
2011 Correspondence Dinner you know
that's when he got mad huh yeah he came
back with AV vengers because he's like
Obama this [__] this [__] that you know
he has a very vengeful person
personality I think I saw a documentary
about that that woman
Amorosa and she was talking and she was
talking about that that that at that
Rose is where he decided he's gonna run
for president they were bashing him too
hard oh yeah it was
hilarious I think the whole thing was
about him and he just came back and he's
like I'm gonna prove you guys wrong I
mean that's the only thing I could say
about Donald Trump you know he came back
and prove wrong but he fcking off a lot
of people you know well you
know what are you gonna do bro
sometimes I feel like he's a little
puppet you know you know Spicer and
whatever those guys name Bon and back I
know but when he's telling the executive
order it feels like he's um like there
was a bunch of people that got together
for a science project and he never
showed up but he's showing up to get
that lat grade A you see you can see in
their face like yes that's how it is dog
there's like No Child Left Behind you he
just long for the ride hell yeah dog you
gotta keep on rolling with the punches
dog yeah man all yeah man what's up
Victor thanks guys getting in so I'll
check you in next month [__] man shining
thanks for calling
keep always
get cool calling on your phone
huh what's up V what up who's what's up
fool what's crack Ling booty smacking
godam what's up f
oh what up who's this Baby
Bash what was
that what's up
fool was cracking I was watching the the
bill bur special just now on YouTube
yeah cuz like a like a broke ass fo
actually more like a lazy ass guy I
don't have the Netflix thing I'm about
to say dog so you're watching on
YouTube Yeah man so a [__] God I can't
get you guys in trouble like that can I
no no for what you ain't using my IP
address so uh yeah it's pretty good man
it's uh it's real Progressive man like
it starts all slow and then it starts to
build Progressive
rasa yeah man and uh I know this a
review uh the review you want to watch
something hilarious go watch one of
those one of those roast they have in
New York I don't think you can see them
but you can hear it and then Bill Burr
comes in at the end and start roasting
everybody there man he start roasting
Rich Voss oh my God man I I would want
to quit comedy after
that I've never seen that oh my God bill
they introduce him as Billy Burr first
of all so it's a old roast and he goes
yeah you're selling out a he goes yeah
you're the funniest guy ever you you're
going out and P right you're hanging out
with open micers
it [__] hilarious bro send me the
link do I send it to you that's not the
Philly one is it or which one are you
talking about I don't know I think
they're roasting um I don't know I don't
know the roasting capric patrici o' Neil
but the roasting they are roasting
patrici o'
Neil no no no no it was a a roast that
they did in the club and they recorded
it send me that I sent it to you bro so
you thought the special was Progressive
bro yeah like it started saw slow like
like his jokes like they they took a
it's Progressive man like right right in
the middle of the special like he really
starts getting into it he starts being
funny you know what I
mean that's the way
show everybody dog he's what he's
roasting everybody like he's talking
[__] on fat people like you need to lose
some [__] weight you know like you
start talking about Trump just everybody
man sounds awesome bro hell yeah dude
[__] yeah that's what's up what else is
cracking fool what else you got to what
else is going on going on bro what else
is on YouTube what Happened dick with me
or what do you mean no with your clone
of course
you what's going on in your world huh
just
uh computer programming bro coding or
what over there Silicone Valley Bro [__]
it it were Snowden
dog [__] type it in bills
bro where you work at
dog uh I I work at
Disneyland don't be lying dog what ride
[Laughter]
bro I I white tables dog I don't I don't
[__] work at rides
[Music]
bro that's cool so you you're you're a
computer programmer at
Disney no no no no no I'm teaching
myself now
right now
like like I'm I'm teaching myself Compu
that's cool bro I think everybody right
now if you're listening if you want a
job in the future all the jobs are tech
jobs now man coding that's the kind of
jobs that are available right Am I
Wrong uh yeah I mean it's cool because
it's something you can teach yourself
and you don't you don't have to go to
like college you can but it's something
you can teach yourself you know you
don't have to it's like a you got to go
to a law school or to be a doctor you
know I mean like something you really
have to go to school to learn it's
something you can teach yourself man
it's another language man yeah man you
got it all planned
out pretty it's boring as [__] I'm not
gonna lie but you know what I mean yeah
man sounds boring yeah you're telling me
dog you're telling me BR I want to we
delete I want to
escape I want to escape out Delete right
now the edible just hit this fool dog
yeah [__] Don't Cry
[Laughter]
d well thanks for calling bro man I know
you have a lot of thoughts to go through
you got to check your checklist next
time F before you call dog I'm just
happy to be here he you started out
strong
dog yeah bro the
progressive well thanks for calling
Homie we love you bro thanks for
listening bro going dog keep learning fo
bro peace peace it's all about knowledge
all right block this
guy now he was cool what you mean block
this
guy well not you bro last listener just
kidding bro [__] we thought you hung
up already who's this Rene saw we saw
your zip your ER code over there what is
it I don't know this is Sergio from from
the north B oh what up what's up Sergio
it's cracking from the north side of
Long Beach what's up the north side of
Long Beach no I'm from
North hella North from nor North of San
Francisco the North Pole from [__]
Uka no not that far north L that's
that's uh what's that prison up that's
Pelican Bay L Pelican
P what's cracking dog What's happen can
you can you guys hear me okay because I
got I'm listening through you through my
death beats while I'm working we can
hear you
bro hey so uh what's the topic of the
day you're the topic bro you dog we want
to know we want to know if you're
worried about being deported
bro n v I got I got I'm Legit what's
legit mean fo what if they ask you bro
let me see your birth certificate bro
you don't have it with
you oh no I thought that's in my back
pocket I carry it with me at all times
no that's your weed licing bro that
don't
count how' you know I thought I just got
it CU you sound like somebody who just
graduated bro
there you go graduated from the church a
night school dog hey hey do do Mexican
parents still look at a marijuana at
bad you know what um it's funny because
I just asked my mom you know she's she's
uh she she's from straight off from
Mexico and uh but she's legal and uh
yeah throughout my whole life she told
me you know no Mi no no Mi that's bad
that's that's thr ass but then when I
just told her hey Mom I got my license
she you do what you got to do be careful
driving buy me something
M hey uh I just want to ask Rodrigo did
you get my package I sent you a package
uh oh shoot when you were down in Las
Vegas with uh Sun ju uh through what'
you send it through
Instagram no no no no no I'm talking
about the the magazine uh the Playboy
magazine oh you know what dude it's in
this pile of uh of mail that I have that
I still got to get get through dog I
just [__] go home to sleep and take
off in the morning dog so I I I'll look
through it but my homie said there was
there's a couple packages unless it's
closed I open it up but I will open it
up what happened bro you s him a Playboy
with all the packages stuck together
it's a Playboy with Felicia
Michaels oh wow yeah yeah collector's
Adam thank you very much though but it's
in a pile dude and I apologize sign it
dog yeah dog take it to the take to the
man funny because you see I I got I got
her I got one sign from her you know
like way back when she was still with uh
Joey
and you know uh she asked me she goes
hey where'd you get this and I told was
my dad told you know what I no no I I
got it at an antique
shop I mean no punch light intended yeah
he's a funny guy no no but but I'll
check it out no it's just this this
antique store that that that I guess
some was trying to get rid of his old uh
you
know put it up there yeah but uh no
anyways um so no back to back to what
you guys were talking about am I the
last caller okay
no another one I can mind reader dog
sorry yeah no sorry if I'm all hyped up
but I just finished my Starbucks and I'm
working right now too it's all it's all
good dog so what were you gonna
say oh nothing just ask me a question
I'll answer
it so man um so you have your license
man um what's the first thing you're
going to
buy
well uh I first well actually I got the
Edibles and uh the reason why I got it
though about uh and be alio I I'm a
diabetic and I'm and I have that
diabetic nerve pain I mean it's you know
my feet my feet are throbbing and feel
like needles on my toes and whatnot is
that when you wake up in the morning or
all
day uh no actually it happens right when
I go to sleep right as I'm going to
sleep uh the pain starts kicking in and
so to alleviate that you know I take a
couple Edibles and then I go to sleep
awesome yeah man hopefully it works out
for you man what's the another that but
um what's the name that edible that we
had the other day Nova Nova right those
yeah those little green it has a little
green it has a little cow with a a top
hat on it it's called Nova yeah I think
that's what they're called I peeled the
the um yeah man you got to try those bro
they're [__] strong dud those things
are killer is it the two 200
milligrams I don't know man but um it's
strong it has six doses dude it put Toby
to sleep yeah mother try act like that
[__] wasn't powerful do they come in
little little little little packages and
you could break them off in four
sections no it comes on it comes L like
a side of a brownie you can break it up
in six it's like a peanut butter brownie
with a a chocolate layer on top and it's
vegan too but they they're not all vegan
though they have the vegan option it's
glutenfree it's a silver package it's
packaged and it has like a green I don't
know if you ever saw a magazine like a
marijuana magazine and I don't know
where it was but Gabriel GLA was holding
one on the front of the magazine fluffy
yeah okay I'll Che or you could just
Google on fluffy magazine brownie or
just fluff gabri glacia on the front of
a weed magazine and he's holding it
gotcha hey just you know a real quick
story um a few months ago I was
delivering refrigerators for pg& uh for
their energy Savings Program and uh up
here in the north bay and we went as far
as up north like uh we went to humo
County and a lot of people out there
hooked us up with butter have you ever
had that
yes yeah that that stuff right there is
the
stuff I've had butter I had sugar I had
tea
wheat
gum so did you like the butter yeah it
was good bro we made um cookies with it
and I have these little cookies little
green one for a while but after a while
I get
tired start turning green
it Creed up on me all right man when I
was holding the this the other side of
the ladder Let It
Go what's up Sergio be cool dude thank
you very much we'll open up that [__]
I'll be at Tommy te's bro February 16th
to the 19 PL in California so hopefully
I'll see you there we'll see you there
hey yeah yeah yeah how about uh how
about any future gigs up here I mean I'm
talking like uh Frisco uh maybe even
Zach this what you do bro um you call up
the comedy club in Frisco and you tell
him to bring Felipe cobs all
right BR bring Rodrigo with you I will
bro but you got to bug them on their
email you got to bug them on their email
on their Twitter and then ask the cobs
or the punchline what's up man you going
to bring Felipe sparza or not just me
whatever favorite comedian you have just
bug The Comedy Club anybody El to
listening man if you want me to go to
San Francisco that's the only way I'm
going to go because it's when the people
speak they listen yeah man oh yeah yeah
man all right guys well you have a good
day man and uh thanks for taking my call
much love from the Bay Area all right
Sergio teini thanks for calling
gracias what's up fol you are the winner
of a Yen yeah man there you
go hello what's up
F what's up dog what's up dog where are
you calling from yeah f
in
big he's right here
bro where you at
bro I'm out here right now Chino bro
Chino Hills 90210 you snuck you snuck
your cell phone in a Chino prison dog or
what no man I I I was coming on you guys
stuff man I I sent you that idea about
having the podcast at somebody's house
remember that I don't remember that yeah
yeah yeah you left that commentary
maybe man one day [__] we got to talk to
the manager first fool that'd be cool
huh oh yeah that' be cool having a
podcast at somebody's house then on the
sudden their mom unplugs
it no more
laugh [__] laughs too much your
[Laughter]
[Music]
grand starting
yeah man yeah man big fan big fan long
time day one this is my second time
calling I called like the first time you
had to call up I called tell that my
wife [__] was getting mad at me
because I would talk about you guys
podcast a lot oh yeah I remember you
then uh yeah I freaking I
seeno that terrible show me and my wife
don't get to go out much man because we
got small kids and that one time we went
out was to see you guys man it was a 11
o'clock show on a Saturday night CU
that's when the kids were asleep and we
got a babysitter so we went over there
and it's uh when I told my comp I said
we're hanging out with lgo [__] we're
hanging out with alien right here big
dog we talking celebrities right here
bro at date night hell yeah and I want I
wanted to meet felip man I mean [__] it
took forever to beat you guys but uh but
I couldn't because
uh he was all drunk and freaking uh and
I guess you had a cold uh you you're
sing with your throat or something like
that I don't know something like that
but good memory bro yeah Malako right
yeah so I was like uh yeah right now my
my name humble ombre yeah humble ombre
humble ombre I know this fool [__] no
you don't no no you left a message on my
ID earlier today and
I yeah we know I'm loyal bro oh no [__]
yeah dude I tell I tell everybody what's
up I I even uh I even did speci for
people to the novel show or whatever
yeah you had in downtown I was like dude
go like is dude just watching Netflix
and go and they went that a blaster hell
yeah I always I always tell you you know
like you know it's funny man you got to
laugh but when I heard that you had when
you got the HBO when HBO got your
special I was man I was like I I started
laughing I was like we made it big dog
we made it we made it though hell yeah
we made it bro it's because of you guys
Bro [__] Yeah dog it's because of you we
made we made it big dog even to my wife
I was like you know everybody gets
Netflix specials what [__] is the
handing out specials you know what I'm
saying but you know you man that's like
Fu Top Dog right there you know
prestigious prestigious bro so I was
like I had explain to her you know yeah
give away
for I should give away four hell yeah
man thank
you so I just want to say I'm a big fan
man I listen to guys every Friday and
even when you guys I even you a couple
messages like hey you know the the
episode ain't up yet what's up you know
you know hell yeah bro you should have
your wife listen to the inch of the
casso yeah
with three kids so my kids I'm a truck
driver so I always you know I every
Friday man are you driving a truck right
now are you driving a truck are you
driving a truck right now n no I just
got here I already got off the truck G
to ask for a little hoot a little honk
next time bro next time bro next time
next time all right man thank you for
calling shout out shout out shout out to
Rodrigo shout out to to Lisa shout out
to M miklo shout out to freaking uh
slippers OG
slippers than you
bro slippers shirts guys I mean [__]
it's funny one one of the funniest
episodes just real quick because I knowa
got a phone calls but when you had a uh
your that old manager used to have that
white boy what his name Barry cat Barry
cats oh my gosh man that
[__] that [__] story by Jean
Simmons and [__] oh man dud that was
hilarious give him some Berry bro
and I'm standing right there with no one
other than Jean
Simmons if anybody knows do you remember
me you [__] me in the
back yeah
but man from I follow that guy too too
to everybody the only one I was kind of
whack with Tom Green but it wasn't you
guys it was that dumb
[__] that D [__] L dude but everybody
else man it's good episod man just keep
it moving keep going keep trucking I'm
I'm right here man and I'll try to go
get out to see you guys more often but
man it's just hard with three kids yeah
man I'm I'm coming back to Ontario this
year like in November I think and I know
you know when you come on T bro it's
like a it's like a like what I like to
say a Raider home game I'm a big Raider
fan so hell yeah ra baby the way FIP
onario that's a phip home game right
there bro hell yeah bro let me tell you
something funny about Raiders bro I was
watching um I was watching Steve Harvey
Family Feud and and they asked this he
was talking to some black girl you you
got anything to say hell yeah go
[Music]
Raiders hell yeah dog cuz she said for
the Bay right for the bay you're from
the bay hell yeah from the bay go
Raiders [__] yeah dude that sh made my
my nipp was hard bro I I was going to
makeing my women crush Wednesday but I'm
married you still have a women crush
Wednesday no cuz she out of nowhere bro
go Raiders dog go Raiders dog oh man
hilarious hilarious but hell yeah I
don't I don't want take too much of you
guys' time man hey bro aren't you
excited about the raid moving closer to
Las
Vegas I don't even think they're gonna
go oh
man I heard they're go I tell everybody
I don't give a [__] where they go they
could go to Iraq for the Iraq V I don't
a
[__] [__] I I thought everybody here
I was [__] put some P back with the
homies I was like man let's go to Iraq
Iraqi rers big dog let's do it homie
[__] H yeah they don't go to Iraq
your
nrows watch right there don't matter
that's a spirit hell yeah bro they're
going to [__] tear down Huntington
Park and just build a stadium in the
city
bro right there they go [__] Arrow
they go to whatever dude
me hell yeah bro were they going to do
the city industry or some [__] [__] big
dig what's up
call all right man keep it moving keep
itci they were going to move to Widow to
um what you say right now that City but
that place they have they have the whole
town it's a um industrial it's
industrial they make they get rocks to
make cement gypsum it's what's it called
a Cory the whole town is a Cory so that
little town they get money from the
other rocks they take out everybody in
that town gets a check because they live
in that town there's nothing in that
town man it's like perfect right there
like the 10 the 60 and then you got the
605 you got a RAC trck yeah bu [__] I
don't know who goes to
it what's up
[Music]
fool what's up F who's this dog this is
CES dog from Phoenix
bro what's up Cesar dog Cesar dog
holding it down in the a what's cracking
over there is ice on your ass what's up
bro hey come bro
[Laughter]
hey what's up bro is the [__] corn
man scared now or
whats I got cool [__] Bro all every
weekend
[__] for like an hour about talking
about his old lady G to whoop his ass
talking about you and this and that
bro up bro what's up bro what you doing
bro nobody tells you nothing
huh just got out of work I got my four
kids around me right now got right here
I all the time
bro say what just got one p hey man you
gotta cover Phoenix more often bro what
the [__] man one time a year ain't
enough I know but you gotta tell the
club to bring me twice a year bro some
comedians do that 10pm prob and then
then then they come back 6 months later
and do laugh out loud but I'm not that
one I'm not that comedian bro don't
bring you to
Tempe stand man you [__] you guys are
[__] awesome dog you guys are funny
as [__] I thought my it every [__]
morning I I rerun your [__] [__] all
the time H yeah
give listen man tell your kids tell your
kids to say what's up
fool what's up hey I'm gonna see you
when you come down here man you're gonna
see me I'm G have the the shirt that
says Phoenix here
hell yeah we'll be waiting for you
waiting for you
bro
bro you guys be good man you guys are
where's your kids at right now at school
no they're right here tell the food and
say what's up fol hey say what's up
fol they're hard just like this fol the
fol are hard bro that little fool sounds
tough say what's up
hell
yeah hey man right on
man over here so we can get you down
here twice hell yeah bro we're gonna
lock him down not let him
out hell yeah shout out to Rocky Point
hell yeah dog yeah you already
knowas bro you out there what I there
before bro it's the first place I ever
bought a soda and put in a plastic bag
in
America hey don't don't need the the hot
dogs over there man they're ferally [__]
thanks for I two of them over there I
over there thanks for the information D
I thought I'd been to a dog caller bro
better late than ever dog hey but when
you guys come down here man I got
something for you dogon like
it I'll be
ready I'll be ready ready
do I'm going be over there I'm going be
on that [__] like [__] Tom Hardy and
taboo all
confused what the hell is that you don't
know what like Mexican moonshine bro
thought you're talking about
aona bring a big old chick
Baka well you bro I'm good there's a lot
ofs here
man I'm good F well thanks for calling
bro shout out to your beautiful family
bro tell them I said what's up fool yeah
man hey you be good man
okay stay
strong one more that's
it all right last call nobody nobody
good what's up that fol was at home bro
like it's like home Vacation by himself
with his family fool that [__] killed me
nobody tells you nothing elanda he that
the kind of parent bro that if he in a
good mood you know what nobody going to
school today man we're going to the park
I like dads like that bro hey you know
what nobody's going to school today man
we're all going to go to the
park he does seem like a fool like that
dog but then you go to the park bro you
have to work though F kill me with like
ice and [__]
no
bro don't care about the immigration bro
[__] no dog call you the the the W word
in a second hell yeah bro they invent to
that we
back shout out to all our foreign
listeners out there
Cleo Carlin Glen Carlin are our
listeners who are listening in Saudi
Arabia you guys are lucky all over the
world all over the girl Africa our 100
listeners in Canada what's up fo hell
yeah
dog India
London ay warrior in Australia what's up
fo what's happening deported that to
America so you can watch the show live
enough for the kangaro in shout out to
Adam Murray his little pigtails bro yeah
man buddy I heard you guys mention me
buddy yeah you in the curl Toby H his
small toes I got skinny toes
F all happy huh holding hands you guys
don't know we had Toby Hicks last week
our listener he hooked up with his high
school sweetheart they're holding hands
just like old days oh in love me and you
and I behind them and [__] avoiding
police all right a big thank you to
everybody from the punchline staff you
know who you are I forgot your names the
little the the bartender guy that's half
half Greek half Colombian and then the
the owner who's Greek he told me how to
say what's up F and I'm Greek Yas Yas Y
and his and his very nice wife who's
Armenian we had a long conversation man
a bunch of immigrants from East Eastern
European hardworking people huh [__]
yeah dude hardworking put their foot to
the floor dog anybody who come from
Eastern Europe bro to America they ain't
[__] around bro they're [__]
working some kind of hard job either at
a restaurant or [__] cutting jewelry
or something who think it's hard here
they think it's easy here I know man
people the immigrants that come from
Eastern Europe and who come from Latin
America most of them come with skills
yeah it's they could do something but
they could build a house they know how
to make cement they know how to do
something they just work dog no matter
what it is hard I don't understand dog
like I'm so happy that my father and my
mother came here when they came here and
they brought me and they put in all the
hard work you know so I would I could
benefit from it because when you say
that these immigrants come here for a
better life but you see them working
these [__] jobs and um sweeping no man
when they say we're coming here for a
better life it's not for a better life
for them it's a better life for their
children and their children so one day
they could stand proud and going bro I'm
an American citizen because my father
had to get spit on and deported and he
wor washing dishes my dad was a welder
from Years bro he used to come home and
work he used to work at a as a Wilder
for um for um pieces of the Panama Canal
according to my mom the big old heavy
machinery thank you father and mother
for doing all that hard work that I
didn't want to do yeah man what's up
fool and my parents they're both
American citizens though they ain't
going nowhere bro oh say can you see and
and which you stand One Nation Under God
indivisible for liberty and justice for
all what's up fool we're out of here
yeah man be
cool